We are taking your calls at six one seven
eight three zero.
Forty seven fifty.
Let's go to our caller from the three zero
four area code.
Who's calling today from three zero four?
Hi, David.
My name is Chris from West Virginia.
How are you today?
Good.
How are you?
I'm doing fine, thank you.
So I had a question about.
I read an article about how Mitch McConnell
was actually trying to eliminate the six hundred
dollar per week that the people on unemployment
are receiving extra.
Yeah.
So just so people know what that is.
Unemployment is a state program.
Different states have different levels of
unemployment benefits because of corona virus.
The federal government is enhancing unemployment
by up to six hundred dollars a week in addition
to what you get from the state.
That's what Chris is talking about.
God.
Right.
So what do you personally believe his motivation
is behind that?
Why?
Why would he do that?
OK.
So it's essentially a way to force states
to have to reopen.
And if you have more and more people who are
lacking the money they need to make ends meet,
you are going to create a situation where
they are more likely to take the risks associated
with going back to work.
I mean, it's really as simple as that.
We we could say more about it.
We could say more about.
I mean, listen, I think it's short sighted
because obviously in the short term, it might
get more businesses reopened.
If in the long term it spreads infection,
it's going to lead to more and subsequent
closures.
But that is what seems to be at the root of
it.
Yes, I believe that if it keeps going on like
this, that a lot of people are going to die.
Yeah, we're going to have to be forced to
read it and, you know, to close again.
I just don't I just don't understand how they
could how they could really live with themselves
after doing that.
So I agree with you if there is another reason.
So I think that's the main reason.
But if there's another reason why Mitch McConnell
is doing it.
I mean, listen, Mitch McConnell is, generally
speaking, skeptical of a lot of social welfare
programs in general.
So I think any opportunity Republicans have
to cut social welfare, they will do it.
But at least with regard to the virus, that's
that's what I think is going on for states
to open by cutting unemployment benefits.
OK, well, that actually makes a little more
sense now.
I appreciate your time, David.
Thank you very much.
All right, Chris from West Virginia.
Very much appreciate the phone call.
Let's go next to our caller from the nine
oh nine area code.
Who's calling today from nine zero nine?
I David.
My name's Shane.
Hey, Shane, what's up?
I was calling to ask you about drummers.
I want to know who your favorite drummers
are.
Oh, my goodness.
There's so many.
I mean, you know, depends on the genre.
You know, you've got somebody like the great
late John Bonham from the 70s rock era.
Steve Gadd is a tremendous drummer, Vinnie
Colly Yuda.
You know, there's just so many so many drummers,
you know, in the sort of Latin space.
TDE or TE's is fantastic.
It's it runs the gamut.
There's just so many different great drummers
out there.
Carter Bofur, you know, from the Dave Matthews
genre, whatever that genre is, it's it's an
almost limitless list.
We yeah.
Nice choices already, really cool.
That's that's my only question.
I appreciate you answering it and I appreciate
your book recommendations as well.
All right.
Thank you so much very much.
Appreciate the phone call.